die verzweiflung vor ort ist auch mehr
als acht wochen nach der flut immer noch
groß vor allem jetzt da der winter vor
der tür steht seit gestern hat unser
bild flut büro in bad neuenahr-ahrweiler
seine türen geöffnet wir wollen die
flutopfer in katastrophengebieten nicht
vergessen und nicht alleine lassen
sondern ihnen zuhören und ihnen auch
weiterhin mit rat und vor allem mit tat
zur seite stehen ich haben uns nochmal
an wo wir unser büro genau eingerichtet
haben dort wo die flut die größten
schäden angerichtet hat und noch immer
deutlich gezeichnet dass wir begeben uns
in den norden von rheinland pfalz nach
bad neuenahr ahrweiler und dort in der
eifel stube werden sie vorhin gesehen in
der armut straße 26 haben sich unsere
kollegen niedergelassen das was von der
eifel stube übrig geblieben ist um den
bewohnern zur hand zu gehen ja da
schalten wir jetzt genau hin für uns im
bild flut büro ist unsere kollegin der
in lena zander hilft packt dort mit an
es ist der zweite tag was spielt sich
derzeit lena dort ab
guten morgen erstmal langsam aber sicher
hat sich rumgesprochen dass wir hier vor
ort sind dass unser büro geöffnet hat
und die menschen kommen auch um uns ihre
geschichten zu erzählen
richte uns welche geschichten hirst oder
was berührt dich am meisten
es sind unterschiedliche geschichten die
wir hier zusammen gekommen sind aber
auch teilweise kleinigkeiten wie
berührend sind wir hatten gestern eine
anwohnerin hier die selbst wirklich
stark von der flut betroffen ist ihre
wohnung ist nicht mehr bewohnbar sie
erzählte dass ihr auto weggeschwemmt sei
während der wassermassen und trotzdem
ist sie hier engagiert sich auf dem
marktplatz hat sich ein kleiner privater
kaffeestand organisiert wo menschen
zusammenkommen können alt wie jung sich
austauschen können einfach wieder ein
bisschen normalität ein bisschen
gemeinschaft erleben können wir fragten
wie können wir euch helfen wie können
wir euch unterstützen und dann kam
einfach diese ganz bescheidene antwort
wir möchten unseren stand gerne schön
machen wir möchten gerne luftballons
hier aufhängen zwar schon welche aber
die sind nicht mehr schön könnt ihr uns
da helfen klar bei so kleinigkeiten weil
solchen sachen wenn das die kleinen
dinge sind die freude machen helfen wir
natürlich auch sofort und sind gerade
dabei die luftballons zu organisieren
gestern aber auch pfarrer maurer hier
der uns erzählt hat ganz berührend dass
die frage nach dem warum sich hier gar
nicht stellt sondern eher die frage nach
dem wozu und auch da bekamen wir die
antwort die solidarität der zusammenhalt
das zusammenwachsen dieser menschen hier
vor ort ist das was jetzt wahnsinnig
spürbar ist und was die menschen auch
motiviert aber trotzdem gibt es auch
missstände und meine kollegen die
musiker dann jeder fahrt und michael
bischoff bahn unterwegs und haben
stimmen hier vor ort eingefangen
frau merkel sie sagten sie werden uns
nicht vergessen aber
nach dem katastrophalen unternehmungen
des bisherigen krisenstabes folgt nun
die katastrophale finanzierung ihrer
zugesagten geldern wir brauchen das geld
jetzt
merkel sie sagten wir werden nicht
vergessen aber hier unten in den
außenbereichen tut sich so gut wie gar
nichts die hat sich bis heute kaum was
getan weil sich keiner um uns kümmert
alle nur versprechungen machen ob das
der bürgermeister ist oder sonst wer die
erzählen uns irgendwas es tut sich
nichts und die gelder kommen genauso
schleppend an oder überhaupt nicht ich
will jetzt von ihnen wissen wie werden
die leute hier entschädigt
weil das ja ist mit bis zu 80 prozent
und wie ist die kommunale entschädigung
weil ich will nicht als bürgermeister
hier meinen job irgendwann mal aufgeben
und der gemeinde denn drei millionen
schulden hinterlassen und darum bitte
ich sie eine klare ansage auch an die
kommune frau merkel sie sagten wir
würden nicht vergessen aber das
entspricht leider nicht den tatsachen
wir wollen etwas außerhalb von gott sein
und die hunderten von helfern wie da war
ist hier keine eingetroffen weil sie
alle
im ort abgefangen wurden und die hilfen
die wir angefordert hat oder die hilfen
der lkw-fahrer rote kreuz die
sagten jedes mal wenn wir angesprochen
haben dafür sind wir nicht zuständig da
können wir nichts machen frau merkel
sagt wir werden nicht vergessen aber wir
sind vergessen worden so jede menge
spenden und so weit gekommen ist aber wo
ist das ich hab nix bekommen die paar
kröten die leichten mir aber nicht um
merkel also es wäre schön wenn wir hier
im alter nicht vergessen würden also ich
selber bin doppelt betroffen ich habe
ein eigenes geschäft das ist total
zerstört da muss ich denke ich mal noch
bis zum frühjahr warten bis ich da
wieder rein kann bin auch privat
getroffen habe also ein haus mit keller
auto alles flutet wurden die
soforthilfen von kreis und land sind
geflossen jetzt macht sich natürlich
darauf ob auch ein bisschen was von der
bundesrepublik kommt frau merkel sie
haben gesagt sie werden uns nie
vergessen aber sie haben uns irgendwie
vergessen sie machen uns die anträge
schwer wir wissen gar nicht wie wir als
sie überwältigen sollen und wir
wünschten wünschen uns sehr würden das
bisschen bisschen für uns leichter
merken sie haben versprochen uns nicht
zu vergessen es ist der kaffee stand
heute für morgen wir sind hier um
menschen vor ort zu unterstützen
langfristig und wir frau von ihrer
unterstützung auch noch nach den wahlen
sie haben uns versprochen dass wir uns
nicht vergessen werden auch wenn sie aus
dem amt sind wenn sie in den ruhestand
gehen ich hoffe dass sie ihr wort halten
und auch die nachfolgende regierung
dieses wort mit ihnen zusammen hält und
nicht einfach sagt naja da die frau
merkel gesagt nein das hat die regierung
gesagt und ich denke mir
ein wort ist ein wort
gerade gehört die menschen hier vor ort
halten zusammen sind solidarisch aber
das problem ist wirklich sie fühlen sich
von der regierung von der politik
alleine gelassen es fielen gelder es
fehlen baumaterialien ist hier die hilfe
die jetzt von oben kommen muss lena
zander in unserem bild fluthilfe büro
vielen herzlichen dank für deinen
einsatz
[Musik]